[Music]
finally The Avengers age of Ultron
trailer has arrived and it's a little
bit of an interesting story
my desi I went to a second screening of
John wick I love that movie so much see
it when it comes out but when I left the
theater I was checking my Twitter and my
notifications were exploding with
everyone telling me the trailer leaked
online it didn't even seem like it was a
half an hour later and Marvel was like
screw it we're just gonna release this
thing officially so I'm gonna talk to
you guys about my thoughts on this
trailer I got a lot more out of this
trailer than I was expecting I was
expecting a few lines and maybe a big a
and maybe like one shot of Ultron I got
some good this trailer actually
does explore a little bit of the plot
and hints at some of the awesomeness
we're gonna receive next May of course
it's awesome to see the Hulkbuster armor
going up against Hulk in this trailer
that's gonna be in this movie I mean do
you have any idea how many people are
gonna be crying when that happens I mean
I'm gonna be crying I don't know if I
can contain myself in all honesty like I
love movies like enemy-and under the
skin and everything but I do like to see
some Hulk punching things I'm wearing an
et Pokemon crossover shirt what do you
think I am but I gotta say the thing
that I am most impressed with in this
trailer is actually a thing that I was
most skeptical about and that is James
Spader as Ultron it's not that I don't
respect him as an actor because I do
he's very talented it just seemed like
an odd choice but I started to tell
myself that so many of these choices
that have kicked ass in comic book
movies like Robert Downey jr. Heath
Ledger Michael Keaton these choices have
gone on to be amazing in their roles and
even Ben Affleck is looking like he's
gonna knock it out of the park in Batman
V Superman after seeing this trailer and
after seeing the CGI implemented with
practical effects and James Spader's
voice I have no doubt that he is going
to be incredible as Ultron and that
Ultron is gonna be a fantastic villain
this trailer definitely settled down my
nerd worries and my nerd nitpicks
and I don't have any more the narration
for the trailer is just epic James
Spader's voice I mean great casting in
all honesty I was worried about it but
it just seems like it's gonna work and
the last shot that we actually do get of
Ultron's speed
it's something very important because
robot you know Loki is such a good
villain and he has so much humanity to
his character and there's so much
emotion that Tom Hiddleston was able to
portray for that character so I was
worried about a robot playing the
villain in the second one like how much
connection can we really have with this
guy but then you start thinking about
characters like Darth Vader you don't
even see his mouth move it is all James
Earl Jones incredibly awesome voice in
just one shot the CGI animators James
Spader's voice in the direction was able
to sell the idea of Menace from a robot
character I'm in I am in I cannot wait
to see Avengers age of Ultron next May
it looks great the special effects even
though they're not entirely finished
already look amazing the trailer seemed
to hint that there was gonna be a more
dark beat down on some of these
characters that we've grown to love
which I am really pumped for because I
love the Avengers it's a very fun
entertaining movie but I am looking
forward to a little bit more depth in
this one and I'm hoping that it comes
guys what are your thoughts on the
Avengers age of Ultron trailer now that
we have officially seen it I can't wait
let me know what you guys think below
and as always thank you so much for
watching guys and if you did like this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]